okay family movie night guys oh whoa
what Will's getting a divorce so call
him we literally haven't spoken to each
other in years call him that's what
friends do
hey how are you
how's the beer business I'm actually the
brewmaster at my own bar now
congratulations you still got that uh
family of yours you want to see a photo
wow there they are
[Music]
[Applause]
so lunch no brunch no I don't have time
for this can't be friends with a girl
there's lots of famous men and women
friends Laura Dern and Sam Neal in
Jurassic Park
[Applause]
you're a friendship with Will
built for
[Music]
the Midwest crisis there's a couple of
teenage girls your whole thing is so
weird and destructive
said we were distracted no we're we're
exactly the opposite we are constructed
we're constructed
I don't like feeling like the second
most important man in your life
it's embarrassing being a mess in front
of you will a much bigger mess than I am
all I want is for you to end up happy
you idiot well I am happy I've never
been happier in my life
send me the invoice
break out of your box do a little nose
candy with us
pay back in the day just like a mild
horse tranquilizer it's a horse
you can't blow it out it's already in
the brain
[Music]
in my defense
thought it was cocaine
and just so I'm clear that's your
defense
the defense rests
[Applause]
[Music]
Bang Bang